fakes now puts up a three
won't go rebound tip misses and jordan
comes down with a rebound
and he's fouled and a good play by
patrick evans doesn't get the rebound
but
aware alert foul deandre jordan
jordan a double double tonight is the
right play
and the smart play you fouled deandre
jordan in this situation where coach was
talking about
now he has to go to the line
steve ballmer isn't that great about
sports though
you're worth like 90 billion dollars and
you still are living and dying on a nick
platoon
corner three and jordan
through the 52 from the free-throw line
this season knocks down the first one
perfect
now a five-point brooklyn lead think
about that james harden misses five free
throws and
younger jordan steps up and hits all net
he's never been a good free-throw
shooter for his career 47
goes one for two leonard has it five
point game
minute ten left lou williams
kicks it out now beverly stops
back to williams williams puts up a
three bang lou williams from downtown
buckler likes the back this team with
him too
one thing of ours will clip us right now
i'm not